Reagan it's more usual than not
deserve protect and defend them the vast
majority of presidents who win a first
term run and win again the Constitution
of the United States and get to take the
oath of office a second time so help me
God congratulations a big reason money
it's easier to fundraise when you're an
incumbent because you have the power of
the office people want to be around the
president people want to contribute to
the president and the and presidents
have a pretty good reelection chance
aye Joseph Joe Biden is the 46th U.S
president eight of his predecessors died
in office and 11 could not or chose not
to run for re-election
there are just 10 who tried and failed
the issues that cost Donald Trump
re-election covid the economy constant
controversies before trump it was George
H.W bush read my lips
he broke that promise which hurt his
second campaign along with a viable
third-party candidate in the race he
lost
the next to lose the 39th President
Jimmy Carter I can't stand here tonight
and say it doesn't hurt we can buy a
primary challenge for his party's
nomination the economy in recession the
ongoing Iran hostage crisis and then
this answer during a debate seemed to
seal his fate I had a discussion with my
daughter Amy the other day before I came
here to ask her what the most important
issue was she said she thought nuclear
weaponry
his daughter was eight years old Carter
lost in a landslide to Ronald Reagan
this report will be my last Gerald Ford
whom Carter had defeated served less
than one full term failing to win in
1976 after pardoning his disgraced
former boss Richard Nixon for the
Watergate scandal the plan is
particularly aimed to economic relief
until that point decades had passed
since the nation had seen another
one-term president Herbert Hoover in
1932 he was blamed for failing to act to
stop the Great Depression the other
presidents to lose the 27th William Taft
the eighth Martin Van Buren the sixth
John Quincy Adams and his father the
second President John Adams all faced
failing economies third party candidates
or a fight from within their own party
one common theme for presidents that win
re-election historically they've needed
an approval rating close to 50 percent
Joe Biden's are not that high but
historians say that might not be a
factor anymore because of all of the
stir that's going on and the churning
and the partisanship and the upset and
the violence that's been happening in
our politics we perhaps shouldn't be too
surprised that it's hard for presidents
to get up even over 50 percent these
days analysts say the biggest challenge
for Biden will be his age the oldest
serving president polls show the
majority of Americans didn't want him to
make this decision now comes the hard
work of convincing them he can and
should serve a second term Patty culhane
Al Jazeera Washington
let's now cross over to Washington DC
and bring in Steve Clemens he's the
founding editor at large at semaphore
he's also the host of Al jazeera's the
bottom line hi there Steve thanks for
your time with us today so uh you saw
that video that was released by uh by
President Joe Biden the the slogan is
let's finish the job is this going to
resonate with voters
well you know it's very interesting that
he started out and really focused on the
negative things that Maga Republicans
represent rather than the positive
things that he has achieved so while
he's talked about finishing the job you
know he's passed a lot of legislation
and got a lot of things through but
that's not where they started this they
started about Donald Trump and all of
the chaos that had come before Joe Biden
and you're really telling Americans do
you want that back and and so you know
basically Joe Biden is running on the
prospect that Donald Trump is going to
be his Challenger right and what about
his age you know a lot is being said
about him being the already the oldest
president in U.S history I mean how much
of an obstacle is that for him
well I mean and beneath you know beneath
their what they say publicly a lot of
Democrats are uncomfortable with Joe
Biden
um you know he probably will win uh
easily the nomination but more than 40
percent of Democrats would rather see
someone else run because I think they do
have concerns about his age that said
there's no consensus on who that ought
to be we're going to have you know
Donald Trump is 76 right now and so when
he runs you know you're going to have
two of the oldest candidates in both
parties running against each other
um and so it's a new phase in history
it'll be historic in that moment and if
and if Joe Biden wins this next race at
the end of his term he'll be 86 years
old which is which is a significant age
I'm not an ageist but there are a lot of
people who have concerns that he doesn't
have the same Vigor and attentiveness to
some of the big policy challenges or the
Vigor if you will to handle the job I
disagree with that assessment I've you
know been around the president seen him
very enthusiastic but do think age is a
big concern to some Democrats all right
Steve Clements thank you so much for
your time
my pleasure